I was posed this question on Facebook so
I thought I'd give it a quick spin
rather than get my full set up and go
out in my classroom I just started
record something here on my desk so I
thought I'd give it a go because it's a
it's an interesting question it's got
some challenges to it this is all I was
given I wasn't given a domain so this
could be a general solution question but
I'm gonna just treat it I'm just gonna
give it a domain like say 0 to 360
because that's that's a pretty sort of
standard domain to assume if this is
general solution question then for the
person is a minute maybe you can let me
know and I'm happy to adjust it though
most of the steps will be basically the
same and it's really the way that you
articulate the answer that is a bit
different but anyway let's move on with
it
now what makes it challenging is you've
got this um this angle up here
excellence to and this X and they don't
sort of play very nicely together with
each other it's hard to make these two
trig functions interact with each other
so you can simplify it so therefore I'm
going to use my double angle results to
to rephrase this question in a way that
gets everything in terms of one trig
function rather than sines and cosines
I'm gonna convert it all into sines
you'll see in a second so the first
thing I'm gonna do is say introduce a
new angle let's let's call it theta so
let's say theta equal x on to okay so
that implies obviously that this X up
here that will be 2 theta ok so I'll use
that in a second before I actually make
the substitution I should note that if
I'm solving for theta which is x1
- I'm gonna solve angles for theta and
that's gonna give me you know angles in
degrees that are actually in a different
domain because X on two if I divide this
entire domain by two you go from zero to
180 not 0 to 360
so I'll just note that down it's always
good to note down restrictions earlier
rather than later so you don't forget it
for later on alright now with this
substitution how does that change my
original equation well it's gonna make
it look like this I'll have six sine
theta minus cos 2 theta and that's
equal to zero so what can I do with that
well
this causes two theta part it's easy to
get that in terms of sines using your
doubling your formula so and that's
gonna actually look like well I'll do it
long for just in case you're not so
familiar with this identity that's gonna
be closed squared theta minus sine
squared theta that's the standard way to
expand it but you may also remember that
sine squared theta is a rather sorry I'm
actually want to get rid of the cos cos
squared theta is 1 minus sine squared
theta on its own using the Pythagorean
identity so if I change that into 1
minus sine squared and I've got a mind
minus sine squared here on the end as
well that's gonna become 6 sine theta
minus 1 minus 2 sine squared theta okay
so that's nice now that I've got
everything in terms of sines I can start
to actually solve this you can see it's
a quadratic equation in sine so if I
move up a little bit let's keep going if
I turn this around a little bit you can
see just to make it more obvious what my
coefficients are that negative cancel
out so V 2 sine squared theta plus 6
sine theta minus 1 now you look at that
you look at these coefficients they're
not going to factorize the earlier so
you might as well save yourself the
effort and just go straight to the
quadratic formula so when used to things
being you know 2x squared plus 6x minus
1 well in this case you've just got
signs instead of X's so you can use
quadratic the quadratic formula just the
same way that you would normally do it
instead of x equals the quadratic
formula you're gonna have sine theta
equals the quadratic formula so that's
going to be minus B which is 6 in this
case plus or minus the square root of B
squared that's 36 minus 4ac minus 4
times minus 1 times 2 that's going to
give me 8 all over 2a which is 4 okay so
simplify that out a little bit you're
gonna get minus 6 plus or minus that
looks like 44 to me all over 4 because
there's a 4 out of there I could sit
fire that surd take a factor of root for
which is actually two that gives me that
so this I can simplify a little bit this
up here so what's that going to become
well I just take out the factor of 2 so
minus 3 plus or minus root 11 on to okay
now you look at that air dam too bad but
I there's some problems with it which
are not that obvious when you're looking
at it in third form so let me evaluate
it let me get some of this is this is
our our solutions first sign fear of
evaluate it and you'll see there's a
there's an issue if you get your
calculator out and you take the the
approximation of these two answers one
of them is obviously the negative
solution and the other one is the
positive solution okay
so your calculator will tell you that
this first one is about minus three
point one six and the second one is
about 0.16 okay you can see your problem
sine theta right what does it look like
well just as a graph you know it looks
like this okay
and it goes on forever and this range
here sign is from minus 1 to 1 right so
you can never go outside that unless you
change the coefficient at the front to
make its amplitude gray so sine theta is
always between minus 1 and 1
therefore this - 3.16 is never a valid
solution there's no value of theta that
you could put into this equation to
satisfy it right so since this
restriction exists therefore sine theta
is only equal to 0.16 that's the only
valid solution okay so when you take
that and pop it into your calculator to
get sine inverse you're going to get
this oh you're gonna get two solutions
is 90 degrees and seven minutes I'm
approximating again so I should put that
in or 170 degrees and 53 minutes okay
so you're looking at that and those both
fit within the domain restrictions we
already know so that's great the last
thing to realize is that we're not
we weren't solving the theater in the
first place our original equation it was
oh it was all in terms of X right you
know like this so since I introduced
theta to solve my equation I should get
rid of theta so that I can actually
produce the final equation in terms of X
so if I come back over here the original
thing I said was that theater is X on -
right
so now to actually get X I just have to
multiply my answers by two so I guess
that would give me so I actually should
have worked this out earlier well this
was obvious that was not so hard
sorry that's 18 degrees and 40 minutes I
think and this second one will become
let's just punch in the numbers I've got
to be careful with these minutes over
here 341 degrees 46 minutes and that's
my solution between 0 and 360